this next conversation uh you guys don't
have to listen to me Nick Sharma is
going to uh be moderating Nick is the
CEO of Sharma Brands uh he's an investor
an advisor uh many brands that he's
worked with or helped create you all
probably be very familiar with uh he's
going to introduce each one of the
speakers uh these are some of the best
cpg Founders in the country if you don't
have a cpg product don't go to sleep you
probably could learn more from them
around marketing branding sales Etc than
you can from other software Founders so
Nick it's your turn ready all right
here's Nick
Sharma thank
you okay well I got the kids meal chair
over here so
um pom first asked me to do this on
Twitter like a week ago and I thought uh
let me actually just bring some experts
so I've got three people here uh their
names and pictures are all here but uh
these are three three people that I talk
to pretty regularly I share a podcast
with one um and is this is it just me or
is there something wrong with this audio
check check is this normal okay sounds
weird to me um so anyways I want to
bring these three people up on stage uh
we got Moy Ali who founded native
deodorant or native you probably seen
native deodorants the number one selling
deodorant most uh stores now own yeah
yeah just come up now yeah you are not
the father
then we've got uh Jui pical who's the VP
of Performance Marketing at fabletics
which is obviously a massive
company and then we've got Ryan babine
who uh previously founded great and is
now the founder and CEO of jool Lee
which is a showerhead
company all right we can sit now okay
so um all right so I've already
announced who you are uh in my opinion
Jui is the reason I brought these people
here Jui is a Cutthroat performance
marketer uh Moyes understands
operational efficiency better than
anybody I know and he might even yell at
you if he sees some fat that can be
trimmed in your business and Ryan
understands customer psychology better
than anybody I've ever seen before so uh
guys if you were about to be introduced
to Bob Iger how would you introduce
yourself that's what I want you to do in
a minute or less so brag as much as you
can in the intro I'll give you an
example my name is Nick Sharma I started
my career doing social media for
celebrities when I was bored in high
school then I joined an adte company and
I started spending about $100,000 a day
uh to slideshow slid shows on websites
doing display ad Arbitrage after that I
joined a beverage company and that
scaled to 40 million a year in Revenue
just on D
Toc and then from there I started a
business called charma Brands which is
where we work with brands
uh like Jolie and febles all the way to
bicardi and Croc so that is my Bob Iger
uh introduction Moyes why don't you go
first uh sure uh Bob that's a great uh
question I've got a great response which
is if you're shooting another Aladdin I
should be your Prince
Ali um I would say uh to Bob Iger um
that I was an attorney for a couple
years uh realized that wasn't for me
started an alcohol business based in New
York City for a couple years and sold
that to a family office and then started
a deodorant business uh where we were a
direct we were direct consumer uh
deodorant business for a few years and
sold that to Proctor and Gamble we were
png's first acquisition in a decade uh
and the only one that has met per uh you
know forecast uh acquisition forecast in
30 years uh and that's what I tell them
let's go you're
hired
ji so usually when I introduce myself I
say hi I'm ji and I spend a lot of this
company's
money but then I get a look and I'm like
but I will actually make you a lot of
money um I've been in Performance
Marketing last 10 years mostly focused
in Celebrity Fashion um I think spent up
almost a billion dollar in advertising
at this point um and did you say a
billion close to a billion yeah wow over
over years but yeah yeah yeah yeah that
that is a lot of money but yeah uh
definitely like grown grown these
companies significantly as well uh you
utilizing paid paid ads and cro and
things like that so
yeah Ryan hey Bob uh I started my career
at ICM I became an agent representing
actors uh for about 10 years and then I
got tired of babysitting very wealthy uh
actors so I went and became a brand
marketer for a small sneaker company
called Puma where we leveraged a lot of
entertainment and content to grow the
business and then I got tired of giving
you all my good ideas away to a company
that didn't appreciate them and I
started my own company called greats
which I sold to Steve Madden in
2019 and then thought the most natural
progression from Footwear was into the
beauty space and started joliee uh
Beauty wellness company that purifies
your water for better skin and hair how
many people here raise your hand use a
Jolie shower
head zero you guys are so people we are
failing so it's all men here you got to
look at it the other way which is you
can get these other custom who raised
their hand is it's a woman there's a
dude right there three okay I gotta go I
seriously this is a horrible I'm I'm
definitely going to buy one after this
conference so amazing all right so the
the idea here we've got uh I think about
30 or 40 minutes uh it'll be
conversational so I'm going to ask you
guys each questions but if you want to
jump in or counter a point or add to a
point feel free to uh so Moyes we'll
start with you in 2017 you were running
your own Facebook ads your revenues were
tens of millions and your marketing
marketing team consisted of pretty much
yourself and maybe one other person you
clearly had an understanding of what
people needed to see in order to make a
purchasing decision how is that evolved
today and what advice would you give the
brands you
advise um that's all that's uh true um
our our marketing department was one
person we were dependent uh you know a
lot on social media advertising and it
was incredible and uh people are always
like you started native during the
Heyday of Facebook ads and I remember
talking to um there were like 25 to 2017
anybody could run Facebook ads and make
a fortune and I remember during the pro
like you know when we were growing our
business I talked to the guys who
started Harry's and they were like yeah
in 2013 when we were running Facebook
ads we saw $4 Cs and that was the Heyday
of running uh Facebook ads then it was
2015 you know I know Brands who are
spending a million dollars a day in 2020
I know Brands who are spending $500,000
a day and jwy might be spending $500,000
a day uh in 2023 and so I I think there
isn't a Heyday like everything still
works uh you just have to be better at
it uh than you were five years ago like
uh you know there's a great uh line in
the wire which is one of my favorite
shows which is the game is still the
game it's just gotten more Fierce uh and
that's what advertising is like um and
if I were to talk to Brands today or
brands that I'm advising I'd say hey you
really have to look at this as a more
complete picture today than you did five
years ago you can't just you can't just
run on Facebook and expect your business
to blow up I bet Ryan does a bunch of
stuff where he gets influencers uh to
talk about his product I bet he got a
bunch of people to do YouTube videos
about his product because what happens
is somebody who finds a product on
Google or uh through a Facebook ad is
going to go to YouTube and look for real
people who are using it and um they're
going to want a video review of it and
that's something that really wasn't um
possible or something you didn't think
about in 2015 or 2016 or 2017 so um I
think the game has changed and you have
to be more adaptable and you have to
think about a lot more channels that
than you did uh five or 10 years ago um
but it's just more Fierce it's still the
same game um on that note Ryan when you
were running great and even till today
every time we talk you say Facebook ads
are a scam don't trust Facebook ads
they're a scam wow you say that no wa
why and I disagree on Facebook so hard
it's not even funny um so wait hold on
so this year according to LinkedIn uh
your own post you'll do $30 million the
business launched in 2021 you have one
full-time employee outside of the two
Founders oh now two no including arent
yes three in total all right three
people in total uh you have 10,000
pieces of content that have been created
just this year um and you only have 31
ads that are live in Facebook so where
we actually have 31 ads you do yeah as
of when this morning so we had turned
off Facebook all together 100% zero
Facebook in June and I just allowed the
marketing team to put them back up cost
cap who's the marketing team there's
three people there it's we outsourced
that part of the business okay so it
just went live yesterday so okay so then
where and how are you building this
business to do 30 million this
year we really believe that um people
influence people not digital ads
particularly those on meta um um we
proved that meta is highly inefficient
although not zero and there are just
better channels the the challenge is
they're not measurable so because we
have 10,000 pieces of content this year
created by actual customers last year
was about
5,000 that really was the spark that got
the word of mouth flowing and and word
of mouth is not new it's been going on
forever in marketing it used to be done
differently like some kid in high school
was cool he wore a certain thing
everybody wanted that thing that's Word
of Mouth marketing that's not scalable
but the effect layers
in um a starting point for us to then
spend
money we we were were focused on profit
our business like Nick said launched
last year we were Pro profitable in the
first five months or in the fifth month
of business and have always operated the
business to a first P purchase
profitability we could not figured we
couldn't make Facebook do that so we we
let users do our marketing for us which
we still feel is the most powerful
although although admittedly the least
measurable and then that allowed us to
spend efficiently across all a variety
of
channels how do you generate 10,000
pieces of content in a year so you're
letting your users do your marketing for
you um what does that look like tell
tell us the it's a mix of just customers
creating content because they're so
excited about what it's doing to their
skin their hair and their health that
they just want to share are they
incentivized to do it not at all no but
but then there's the other part of that
which is just content creators we we
will send a Jolie to anybody that asks
for one that has a legitimate account
whether they have a hundred followers or
a million followers
and we we are very fortunate in that for
every 10 units we send seven get created
seven pieces of content will get created
so that's a pretty big hit rate and we
don't think that would happen in eyewear
or yoga pants or Sneakers but for us as
a category Creator providing the value
proposition that we do we have that hit
rate so it's it's worked really well Jui
on the other hand um you know fabletics
did 700 plus million in Revenue last
year the collective of companies is
probably top five Advertiser in the
world in terms of deploying media
dollars where do you see uh the biggest
opportunities or growth levers without
seeing a decline in
performance yeah I mean so we're fashion
so it's a very Trend heavy as well so I
think it really helps that we have uh
new collections coming every month so
that keeps things exciting and I also
think you know like uh F letics has just
done such a phenomenal job with
celebrity Partnerships that's kept
things really interesting as well so we
recently did a collaboration with Chloe
Kardashian and you know people loved it
um so I think outside of just paid ads
you have have to have some of that
excitement and differentiator um because
otherwise you're just going to find 20
different Amazon dupes of yourself out
there so with the celebrity Partnerships
you know you've done Khloe Kardashian
you have ads that constantly run with
Kevin Hart um you have the brand that
launched with Rihanna Savage X Fenty
what did the celebrity Partnerships do
for the brands that would have otherwise
costed tons of money like did it save
you money did it get you in the right
door did it open the door for the right
opport opportunities like what did
having a celebrity do for you as a
performance marketer to grow the brand
yeah I mean the halo effect is always
there right because they all they also
have their own audience which is pretty
large um and then it also gives you
legitimacy um it gives you um some of
that influence and stuff that they have
so that definitely helps it makes you
cool um so it's been it's been really
great to have that is it primarily an
upfront cost working with celebrities
like that or is it primarily a residual
cost yeah so I mean there's different
deal types and I just don't I don't
speak for just ftic it's like everything
in general I mean you have the flat fee
cost which you can work on you have the
flat free plus equity which is new now
people have realized the value of equity
and then uh the third one would probably
be flat fee plus percent of unit sales
so there's various options uh that you
can work with them
on which one do you guys do the
most I actually don't should I do
that I don't details of that so yeah
Ryan when you were managing uh
celebrities back in the day which one
would you have chosen which celebrity
that I represented uh yeah like which
deal type would they choose is it cash
only cash and rev share or cash per it
would be more performance bace less
lease cash more performance and
unfortunately you know in in the Creator
world that is an
uncommon uh structure which sort of
tells
you how valuable they feel they are
right you can you should structure it
where you can make a ton more money if
you sell more product most content
creators will not take that deal and I
think that's part of the problem with
the industry so if we look at BR like
everybody here has a liquid death uh can
of water liquid death aspires to be
anywhere where the where people are
feeling happy entertained or uh you know
basically wherever the party is
companies like hims and Roman you know
they've done a great job in the early
days taking over you know the the area
behind home plate or Subways or a plane
that you know basically says we sell
dick pills how important do you think
picking a lane for distribution is and
staying within that I feel like with
Jolie you guys have really picked your
lane as your you know your everyday
customer versus going in like Jolie's
big enough to be spending almost
anywhere but you've pretty much focused
on customers how important is that and
why have you chosen that one lane in
terms of where we spend money or how we
are perceived as a brand both as a
beauty wellness company we wanted to
make sure we showed up in that lane so
we we wanted to make sure that we were
not perceived as a piece of Hardware
that pushes out water which is what a
showerhead does we provide a utility
that improves your quality of your skin
and your hair beauty Wellness Hardware
not shower Hardware so we had to
differentiate that way and that was
going to be in terms of how we showed up
where we showed up you know one of our
biggest accounts is airwan I was telling
J this earlier we went live in all doors
Awan in May they've reordered every
single day since they went live that is
not an overstatement they have no room
for storage so they can put 10 units per
store and every day they buy another 10
units we've never seen any perform thing
like that at any retailer so showing up
in the right place was really critical
especially in the early years now we can
start to expand out a little bit um but
we're we're still currently to this day
you know we're on revolve we're on Blue
Mercury we're on Nordstroms and Sachs
but we're in the beautyer section and
we're going to retain that for the rest
of the year and then we'll go a little
bit wider
um in terms of how we
Market 70% of our audience is women
which frankly personally I was surprised
I didn't think we'd get 30% men um so
that early data point sort of changed
the way we Market it because it's not
just women that are buying Jolie and we
see a world where it's going to be 50/50
men shower every day or at least you
should um and they appreciate the B they
appreciate that benefit it's a really
convenient way to improve your skin and
hair regimen without doing anything
different right you're you're going to
shower anyway you might as well make the
the water better um Moyes Ryan talks
about getting into air one you held off
on all retail until post PNG acquisition
which was probably one of the many
reasons they bought the business if you
were to relaunch today uh would you
still hold off on retail that
long um great question we held off on
retail for a couple reasons one was uh
we
were um trying to do it just in time
inventory you know when we started the
business we were ordering 500 units of
deodorant uh a week and within 18 months
we were doing about 21,000 units a day
and uh so we had a hard time keeping up
with production that we needed for our
own website and that was one of the
reasons that we held off on retail I
think today you know I would lean into
it much much sooner um because I think
that like the path for an omni Channel
brand in 2015 really hadn't been paved
only only Harry's had done it before and
today Harry's has done it quip has done
it native has done it manscape so many
brands have sort of uh walked that path
where you know what to expect you know
what the retailer is going to want you
understand the exclusivity they're going
to want you understand what the terms
are going to be like um you're not a
Pioneer and I think it's uh it's always
um a little bit scary and a little bit
profitable to be a Pioneer and um I
think that we did it at the right time
for us uh today I'd be like you know
what I know a little bit more of what to
expect and how to handle this um and I
have a little bit more belief in my
business and we've got a lot more cash
to be able to invest in inventory uh and
so I probably would have done it sooner
uh I'm curious to hear when Jolie will
be available in Home Depot then in your
head will it be 2025 or is it too soon
because it's a beauty and not a I think
we've proven that we're a beauty
Wellness tool so we and and we did that
without Ulta and Sephora which
originally I thought we would need no
matter I think you've proven as well I'm
just curious when do you see Home Depot
as being like we've got to unlock this
20125 would probably be the earliest
okay but I can see myself showing
up in Costco sooner because if we look
at the customer
profile moms are going to Costco and
they're spending a lot of money they
spend a lot of money every single week
and there's 300 million showers
residential showers in the US that's a
lot of showers
we can capture a lot of that audience in
Costco the challenge with Costco as you
mentioned on your last pod was they're
just really good their membership
program is means that you're giving it
to them for Less full stop that's it
we've done the math the business is
profitable day one if we go to Costco
and the reach is massive it just the
size of their business is so enormous it
would dwarf the best year we could
possibly do at Sephora and Ulta together
in one year so
so as a profitable business that we have
that sort of luxury now to sort of pick
and choose where we we should go and we
might as well go for the most profitable
scale Channel out there ji today fatic
has 95 of its own retail doors around
the country um opening those retail
doors as a brand that's doing hundreds
of millions of dollars what did that do
for the brand in terms of allowing you
to expand on marketing or building the
brand or bringing new people into the
ecosystem yeah a quick question um so I
think some of the advantages of starting
first as digitally native is you know
where your customers are you have all
these other extra data points so that
really helped also with like where
exactly to start opening stores and
things like that I also think like just
you know it tremendously helped from a
Omni Channel point of view because like
we're a subscription model and so it's
pretty easy for our members to go in and
do returns exchanges things like that
and then like touch and feel the product
uh and they can still buy the product at
their membership prices um so it just
gave them an extra touch point which
really helped as well and then I think
also from a brand awareness standpoint
it was tremendous because when you
actually see a brick and mortar
storefront like that it's like well this
is legit not just like an online brand
um and then they can touch and feel the
product which I think is massive so
Moyes I'm only 27 but my
grandchildren my grandchildren uh are
going to know about Native because it's
still going to be in the store and it's
still going to be selling at High
Velocity just like a tide or Old Spice
will at at that time too what do you
think are the characteristics of a brand
that lasts 100 years that is a really
good question um you know I didn't I
wasn't a good uh CEO in terms of like
being a good boss to the people that
worked with me uh but I still remember
the like we'd have these quarterly
meetings and I would say uh tide was
launched in like 1946 and in 1952 became
the number one uh selling laundry
detergent the United States and it has
never lost that mantle and when people
think about tide they think about their
mothers uh doing their laundry when
their kids and like playing in the yard
and uh their mothers pampering them and
treating them well and you know putting
their clothes away in their dressers and
um I was like tide isn't a laundry
detergent it's a family brand and that's
what Native has to be um it has to be
this thing that when you use it you
think about your family in health and
wellness and not just smelling bad uh in
fact like you you have to think about
what this means and what it represents
for your health and um you know you're
you're investing in your body and um I
really tried to convince uh when we were
marketing I was like that's how we're
trying to sell this product we're not
selling you a product that's going to
make you smell better we're letting you
invest in your health in a way that's
going to affect you and your family for
the next 50 years um and so that's what
we were trying to do the other thing I
would tell our customer service team in
in particular is I was like look um one
time there was a British prime minister
named Margaret Thatcher who uh somebody
this like uh Irish terrorist group tried
to assassinate her and they blew up a
bridge and they missed and they called
up the prime minister's office and
they're like um you were lucky this time
we missed um you have to be lucky every
time we only have to be lucky once uh
and then we're going to get your prime
minister and I was like we uh we are
like the British prime minister we have
to be lucky every single time you
interact with consumers you've got to
think that you you're representing this
brand and you've got to realize that you
know thousands of hours of work have
gone into this brand both by me but also
by your colleagues here and so every
time you talk to a customer you've got
to think about how important the you
know how important your colleagues are
to you and how important this brand is
and so you can't be mad at somebody and
talk to talk about the brand you've got
to represent it and treasure it in a way
that um you know will last 100 years
right
with um with Jolie which is essentially
a hardware
showerhead uh showerhead plus a filter
you position this as a beauty tool
versus something that sits in Home Depot
or Lowe's what was the reason behind
that
multiples not not entirely but um partly
you know we really if you think about
the bottled water business and you
mentioned liquid death 40 years ago
there may have been two or three water
bottled waters in the on the Shelf today
you go into a store there's hundreds it
became the norm to drink bottled or
filtered water we believe that everybody
in the US is going to filter their
shower water at some point in the future
I don't know if it's 5 10 20 years we're
the market creator of that that is not
just a piece of Hardware that is an
essential Beauty Wellness tool we call
it Step Zero no matter what product
you're using for your your hair and your
skin if your water is contaminated and
sadly all of it is then you're starting
at a negative we want to bring that
negative to zero and we're going to be
the first to do it and then there'll be
many many other competitors and that 300
million showers in the US will be
hopefully number one Jolie and then a
bunch of other players in the space
which you would expect it's a really big
Market but that's how that's why we
positioned it that way if you know we do
a post-p purchase survey the number one
shower brand in the world is Coler
they're 121 billion privately owned
company ker is the dominant player when
we survey post purchase we ask what
brand of shower are you replacing with
Jolie um 40% don't know they don't even
know the brand of showerhead they have
which is an amazing opportunity for us
it means we can brand the space where
40% of those 300 million don't even know
the other 40% are Coler and to disrupt
150y old privately owned family
business in a year and a half is pretty
powerful so we feel we have a long way
to go obviously but I think we're on the
right path on on how to build a legacy
brand with uh Jolie's marketing uh
whether it was intentional or not
there's basically this formula that I
see which is if you use Jolie your hair
skin and Nails will become beautiful
stronger healthier if you stop
subscribing you'll get ugly this I think
has contributed to your churn of 6% no
no no no I have to correct that okay
it's 3% 3% yes okay 3% which in
comparison to Netflix which is you know
the world's greatest churn system is at
2 and a half per. how do you think your
you know how have you built subscription
in a way that it is competing with
Netflix in a year and a half and is that
formula a reason as to why it does so
well I don't think it's the formula of
the content I think it's the efficacy of
the product it really does that we have
like I said thousands and thousands of
customers that create content of what it
does so this is what my hair looked like
before I used Jolie this is what it
looked like the next day that's a really
powerful statement so when somebody sees
an improvement in their skin and their
hair which is you know vanity is a major
driver for all of us as as as humans and
then consumers and you when you can when
you can add value to that to vanity you
have a really powerful product it's why
beauty is so strong so back to the you
know the multiple thing the reason
Beauty companies get bigger multiples is
because of that and we think the beauty
industry at large has overlooked the
number one source of many of the
problems that they've been prescriptive
about you have dry skin use this lotion
you have frizzy hair use this treatment
you have exzema put this on so many of
those literally start with the water you
shower in every single day from the time
you're set seven till you die and we
just couldn't believe that the entire
industry ignored it and that's where
Jolie plays Jui the the founding team at
fabletics has a ton of Brands Savage
Fenty fabletics fabfit fun just fab
shazzle yidi Etc the the subscription
model is so common across all of them do
you think that that's a model that can
be replicated across other Industries
and if so
how yeah okay first of all they don't
faf fun is not part of it but um yeah I
think I mean I think it's pretty
incredible what they've done with the
Innovative membership model um and how
much it's scaled with an apparel uh I
definitely think yes it can be across
other Industries too especially cpg and
Stu of nutrition and things where you
actually need it um I think the most
valuable thing that they've done is um
just how they've made the membership
very valuable over time so like you know
like fatic for example um just continue
to introduce new categories and things
so now you have more to shop for and you
have more access so you know we
initially started with the women's line
then introduced the men's line um
started the shapewear line and then this
year even have fatic scrubs so trying to
be like your house for everything you
know um and then it's like I like how
our co-founder describes it because he's
like it's like walking into your
favorite store and having 20 to 30% off
at any given time so that's a special
perk you get early access to drops
things like that um so just trying to
create more value for the membership
over time how does the membership work
with an inore model actually so like do
you have to be a if you if you're a
member and you you can only walk into
the store if you're a member or you get
a bigger discount if you walk like how
does that work no you can uh shop as a
retail guest as well like as a
non-member or two um but you would be
buying at the MSRP the full price um and
if they were doing any discount during a
sale period you would get that on the
sale price so no you're not limited to
that um but if you are a member and you
go in you still get access to your
membership special pricing and things
which you can claim in the store you can
also um do your um returns exchanges and
things online and then go to the store
as well so it helps y Ryan you've never
discounted with Jolie why no discounts
well in the time we launched Jolie there
was no funding happening for D to see
anything so you were going to have to
figure out how to get profitable really
really quickly one of the worst best
practices in my opinion and I've I've
I've started this is my second one so
the first one sold I don't did Native
discount on first purchase probably it's
a best practice uh if you B we bundle
you bundled it exactly you want a bigger
card size and these are these are what
we all did greates did the same thing if
you just use 20% it's you're giving back
20% of your
aoov before this customer even starts
with your brand and that is not a good
practice it is is not a good practice in
brand building so with Jolie we just
took a hard line that we were never
going to do that so to this day we've
never discounted not on Black Friday
Cyber Monday not any holiday Labor
Day could I have grown the business
faster probably could we do things that
would spike Topline but if negatively
impact bottom line yeah but that's not a
great business so we wanted to build a
great business and not one that was
venture
focused because Venture if are there any
venture capitalist here raise your hand
come up here I'm going to hit you no I'm
kidding um Venture just has a different
agenda right their agenda is very
different than building a very
profitable Sound business and um after
the second after the first business as a
second time founder you learn a lot and
our Focus was to get profitable and not
discounting is one of the if we gave 20%
on $150 that's $30 per purchase that
we're literally torching in into the air
that's a lot we we have over 100,000
customers so you can do the
math Moyes if you're thinking about
future proofing a business after you've
scaled it from zero to selling for a
$100 million how would you advise
yourself to Future proof your business
when you're at $10 million so that at
that $100 million level you know the
things that you wish were done had been
done um great question I think that I
did a very poor job of this but I would
say it's hiring really great people I
think the way you future proof your
business is to make yourself not
obsolete because I don't think that's
possible or a good thing but you want to
hire people who can run a business in
case you get hit by a truck um and who
understand the brand ethos really well
and I think all of the founders who sort
of have stepped down and found another
great CEO to run their business is
someone who lives and breeds that person
like you know that Founder's vision and
understands it really well and it's not
so like you know when Walt Disney died
the Disney board would always be like uh
what would Walt have done and that was a
big mistake because um that ran them
into a bunch of trouble and I think it
was in Steve Jobs's biography by Walter
Isaacson he's like don't ever ask that
question don't ever ask what would Steve
Jobs do do what you think is right I've
trained you in a way where your judgment
is going to be the right judgment and I
think that's really important is um just
hiring leaders organ of an organization
that you can try
that understand your vision but also
understand when to depart from it
because there's a unique opportunity or
a unique uh it's a unique moment in time
um and I think I did a mediocre job of
that at best um and Ryan I'm not sure if
you only got one employee how you're
doing so far uh but I think I'm actually
doing really well it was easy I one
Higher it was super easy I think that is
really important is uh to Future proof
your business you should train a
generation of leaders that can go after
you and do a really good job and execute
at a high level
Jui right now uh as of last month
American credit card debt has passed a
trillion dollars how do you think about
making sure that you are not slowing
down in terms of bringing new customers
into the
ecosystem and what are the things you
think about in order to prevent that
from happening I think with ftic is you
know like um the company was founded
with the notion that leggings shouldn't
cost a 100 bucks you know so we wanted
to give a lot of
uh options and variety and fashion
colors and things like that uh without
breaking the bank so I think that gives
a little bit of Advantage because it's U
you know affordable um and the
membership too you know like the first
purchase that you make um to try the
membership you get a a great deal to try
it out so it's like two two leggings for
$24 when you sign up for the first time
and uh I think with that it's just an
additional value prop too right
especially in times like this so um yeah
all right pom gave me the uh the couple
minute countdown here and um so I want
to wrap it up with this for each of you
guys what is one thing that you're doing
or you're looking at today that you
intrinsically feel is a secret weapon
that other people are not doing so what
is one thing you do on a day-to-day
basis or what is one data set you look
at that you believe other Founders or
other you know marketers are not looking
at that they should be it could be an
unlock for
them uh yeah I look at the Facebook ad
accounts of probably 10 different
businesses on a daily basis um totaling
a million dollars and spend on every day
uh to have an understanding of like you
know what does CAC look like how is
direct consumer doing in general um and
I feel like that is a superpower because
you're just like I understand what
business I understand how people are
going to feel today because I know what
their CAC was yesterday um and uh maybe
I don't know how Ryan's going to feel
he's probably smiling at that uh but
otherwise I feel like that's my super
power uh for me I think uh conversion
rate is really important like keeping an
eye on it and constantly erating on it
because if you're spending thousands and
thousands of dollars but your site is
like a broken car then you're just
losing all of that money so um just
constantly making sure the conversion
rate stays up it's probably more what
we're not doing um because we just don't
do a lot of the best practices in the
industry discounting is one of them we
don't even collect emails in a Emil
popup anymore we turned that off about a
year ago and we
saw you know my co-founder was like hey
but everybody else does this and I'm
like Hey we're not in the email capture
business we're in the cell Jolie
business so let's test this see what one
works better this one worked better so
there's just I mean you know every
different every business is different
but it's what works for us um but one
little hack that I'll I'll sort of just
put out it's not even a hack it's a it's
a tool no. is probably the most
important plugin I've ever used in my
entire career it ju all it does is make
your page load speed faster which we all
know is valuable we don't know how
valuable until you really see it we
turned it on about four weeks ago I I've
again never seen anything in my life uh
with that kind of value in terms of what
it does to page speed and then
conversion and then of course the the
longer effect will be CAC which
continues to
drop all right well that is all the time
we have feel free to hit us up on social
media link in email whatever it be and
thank you for the time
today